well uh let's let's let's jump to the
bad news i guess
or bad news oh yeah it's a different
kind of bad news for all the people that
think you know what i don't
live in these cities i don't care what
new york does i don't care what
california does
i've been saying that i'm like hey look
i live in the middle of nowhere well
here you go everybody
the blue state exodus americans fled new
york and california for republican
states of arizona idaho
and the sun belt to escape lockdowns and
skyrocketing crime
so the people who voted in these these
crooks and criminals and
the democrats who bring about failed
policies and all those who overlap
will now be coming to where you live and
voting for those exact same things
so you are going to vote the same yep
and i think this goes back to what i was
saying because i will stand by this i
think that the
liberals have a sense that they have a
moral high ground
i think they believe in their morality i
don't think uh i just i don't think so
i think they do i think some maybe i
think that's the ethos i mean i don't
know about
you know for example joy reid or whoever
else uh
in the media but individuals that i
speak to who are on the left
are pretty sure that their empathy and
compassion-based
approaches to you know politicizing
whatever
are exactly right this is the moral
perspective to have
i i disagree i think they're paranoid
delusional psychopaths
who hold con different
paradoxical more moral views that make
no sense such as
they do make no sense i'm not saying
they're more organizations there's no
moral framework
like no it's not effective but no
believe it there's no i i don't think
i mean i don't think you can say they
believe things that contradict each
other because then one contradicts the
other
like when they come out and say stop
asian hate and we need to
end these things and then you point out
that the specific attack they're
highlighting so
for example they did a march to end
white nationalism yes because a black
man attacked an asian guy
that's correct how can you have a moral
framework when
they're like it's it's there was an
article that came out shortly after that
that defined
um you know a black person attacking an
asian person
as white supremacy because of ingrained
white supremacy that's that's
that's i'm imagining trying to build i'm
saying they
believe whether they whether it's it's
but it's like but
that's logical or not that's like that's
what makes it a religion it's not
logical
i i understand what you're saying about
belief but i don't think belief is the
right word because if you show them a
picture of a
of a blue cube and say what color is
this and they say red
and then you and then you say close your
eyes and open your eyes now what color
is it they say green
how do they believe it's both red and
green at the same time when it's blue
you see my point
i mean are there four lights i mean it's
like it's not it's not belief
it's like it's it's it's it's something
else it's zealotry it's blind
faith that whatever they're doing makes
sense even when it doesn't
they don't believe one thing they don't
believe that you should stop asian hate
when they cheer for the beating of andy
no
they correct they don't they don't they
don't want to end white nationalism they
think they do
i i don't i think or maybe even more
they feel they do
i the reason i disagree to a certain
extent
but if if the if the thing they believe
in changes every minute
how can you say they believe it because
i think they do
but how can they so it's like if you ask
them do you think
saying how can people have the kind of
cognitive dissonance that makes them
believe in a complete moral fallacy no
no how can you say someone believes
that uh asians are oppressed when
literally a minute after they say it you
ask them again they'll say they're not
oppressed
so so clearly the second time they say
something totally different
contradictory to what they said before
they can't believe the first thing or
the second thing or they're just not
actually
thinking anything through with any kind
of framework
so there's no belief structure there
that's literally just my trusty
structure i don't know you're my enemy
and i think that there's a righteousness
and i think that there's a feeling of
moral superiority i don't think it
checks out
i think it's actually much more simple
they don't believe anything other than
you are the enemy and if you approach
them and say anything that falls
outside of their cult they'll just say
no matter what it is i'll agree with it
if it means i'm opposed to you
right but how are we supposed to have a
dialogue with these people
you don't but they're half the cut like
aren't we pretty much like split it was
like 75 million voted for trump and like
81 million voted for biden or something
like that most
mo how are we supposed to deal with this
i mean do you really think that we're
looking at a future where we're going to
have an america that's
divided yes i mean we already are yeah
like we're looking at can't we try and
imagine a better future than that
well i think there's realism and
idealism we have the story we literally
pulled up is that people
are fleeing states for other states
what's happening in a lot of ways if you
look at like new york during the
pandemic is that the wealthy people of
means
flee to the suburbs and they flee to
reds red states now many of them may
actually start
and probably will start voting for
democrat policies but the people in
california who like
the their tribe and their strange moral
shifting sands will stay there gavin
newsom can violent all the lockdowns
can be found in the in the fancy
restaurant with no mask on and they
stand by him simply because
that's what they're supposed to do fauci
can change his answer every other day
and he did
and they'll stand by him because our
tribe is the right tribe
the divide is becoming so insane that
right now you there's no agreement on
what reality even is no there's that's
very peculiar
you you ask someone on the left no one
even knows what the what men and women
are anymore
exactly and i go to my friends and i'll
say i see a post on my facebook from
someone i've known from you know
when i was growing up in chicago and
they'll say look at this insurrection in
in in dc and all that and i'll talk to
him and say i hear you it was bad
what are your what's your opinion on the
antifa blm riots and they say what riots
right literally a fear of people in
every major city and even small towns
smashing up windows
and they're like i don't know what
you're talking about that's not true
that never happened stuff is still going
down in minneapolis i think
it is absolutely drive-by shootings
seattle but i think there was like there
have been like riots and stuff in
minneapolis recently yeah portland
yeah and just even coming in i saw like
there's a bunch of demonstrations in
midtown manhattan and police are like on
twitter
stay away from the demonstration in
midtown manhattan in my opinion what's
happening right now
is sort of what happened in orwell and i
think this is plan organized
insanity chaos where the ruling elites
get order out of chaos and just like in
1984 they had people admit that two plus
two equals five
there's literally people arguing on
twitter that two plus two equals five
right now
because math is sexist and that's not
even a joke and and
i actually had your article that you
mentioned up ready to talk about this
before you even brought it up and this
was an article
that yahoo news published that was
titled white supremacy is the root of
all
race related violence in the united
states and it says
in there quote so when a black person
attacks an asian person
the encounter is fueled perhaps by
racism but very specifically by white
supremacy
white supremacy does not require a white
person to perpetrate it
it's a cult it's insanity well that's it
like that's i'm thinking like it doesn't
there doesn't need to be continuity in
it right because
like people have this yearning to like
be part of something and people have
this hearing to be part of something
bigger than them and it doesn't always
need to have all the answers
in order to provide those services for
what they're looking for like
this is way more than a political
ideology this is like a lifestyle
it's just like a mindset it's a religion
a community it's a religion
absolutely it's serving all the purposes
and like if you talk to somebody
like and i'm not like if you talk to
somebody who's really religious
and you show them you know dinosaur
bones
right there are a million different
answers depending on who you talk to
that justify and recon
reconcile the religion with the dinosaur
bones even if it totally
undermines what they're saying right it
doesn't matter they were put there to
test
us exactly that's common and so you know
and at least religion comes by it
honestly at least religion is like i'm a
religion
but this is different because it's a
political ideology and it has to do with
wielding power and it has to do with
policy and it affects all of us like at
least
religious people are chilling like
they're not bothering you
the catholic church certainly used to be
like that though i mean
fair enough but in quebec especially
right oh definitely yeah no of course
but i just mean like this is a democrat
like this is a major party
now now i'll put it this way i grew up
in an era when the moral
uh religious uh you know conservatives
were you know pushing religion and
pushing this this ideology and
uh it wasn't this bad because i'll tell
you this
as much as i can say i believe in a
separation of church and state i don't
think we should have religion in schools
or whatever
one of the problems we have right now is
that the cult of woke
whatever whatever these people are it
doesn't even matter what their moral
framework is or what their beliefs are
they don't have one
by the way it's shifting sins but it's
just whatever their tribe says is right
it's it's it's right no matter what
it is a religion and how do you separate
what they
what their religion is from government
and from schools the other thing i'll
mention is
at the very least the moral framework
from the the the judeo-christian values
that have created
you know a lot of this country they
provide for
innocence until guilt is proven they
provide for a lot of the rights that we
have
god-given rights now not i'm not a big
fa
fan of any specific religion or or
theism or anything like that
but i can certainly look at one religion
where they're like okay
you get a fifth amendment the other
group the other religion says
we don't care if you're guilty or not
we're gonna burn you at the stake that's
actually the joke we make about the
salem witch trials
if you know what's the monty python
thing if she floats then she weighs the
same as a duck and
also a wood wait like it made no sense
they were condemning you without due
process
if she floats she's a witch and if she
drowns she's innocent well that was the
actual
that was the actual thing if she drowns
she's innocent
what they're doing now with cancer
culture they become religious moral
zealots
like without the enlightenment we never
get rid of slavery
another thing we should acknowledge here
is that the bible is currently being
written
through social media algorithms and i do
think social media algorithms are making
people go insane and that's another
aspect we really have to entertain here
because
ever since we had the onset of social
media we had
self-harm suicides depressions anxiety
panic attacks other mental disorders
drastically go up and i think you know
we're trying to understand
the the the madness it's madness it's
insanity it's people who are not well
off who are
off of their rocker who are saying if a
black person
attacks an asian person it's white
people who are responsible for this
which is utterly crazy to even think
about
it's people arguing two plus two equals
five literally
these people you know are not in right
in the head they've been
institutionalized
they've been going along with what
society expects of them what is planned
by them by the elites going to school
going into their indoctrination camps
going in through watching the television
paying attention to social media and not
even getting a point of view out of out
of that control grid
that is shaping these minds to be where
they are right now where
there's there's you know people talking
about fat phobia being racist
there's toddlers twerking in new york
city a place where six people were shot
last night and the mayor right now
his major initiative is regulating
scooters let's let's let's talk about
where these
come on those are really annoying i love
let's talk about where this ideology
ideology leads us the thing the one
thing though i would like to say is that
so all of this woke religion comes
after the decimation of mainstream
christianity and i think it shows us
that
society wants religion and society wants
a religion and if we don't
actually embark upon the creation of
religion in a
in a reasonable way we're going to end
up with complete batshit madness
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you